[Music]
injustice served News submitted by Gio's
tattoos our COO oh thank you very much
when she's got the Polynesian tattoos a
cop was arrested in tears by his
colleagues after he suspected a black
man a cop was arrested in tears into are
we supposed to feel bad he's a baby oh
so he was being arrested because they
caught him trying to blackmail someone
good and the blackmail was he left an
envelope filled with photos of that
victim visiting a prostitute and saying
like I'm Attila
oh you're like these photos are gonna
come out if you don't give me a certain
amount of money oh that's a good kind of
extortion though good and then how yeah
you know we'll obviously that person
shouldn't be [ __ ] hookers right guys
without telling his wife if he told his
wife that's fine how do you know he's
even married you're making up all this
backstory if you'd not married and no
one would care it depends on what he's
doing with the money
what do you mean he'll want these dues
and the money for good purposes then
what you're saying is true it's good
black now oh yes I think it's all steal
from the rich give to the broke trying
to have your back here I think it's all
bet we'll see yeah prostitution is
illegal but it's also illegal for cops
to blackmail exactly they're suppose
uphold the law it is to be righteous you
don't know what it's like to be in as a
cop you know I'm saying to be really in
and undercover and like you're in yeah
is the undercover I watched Donnie Darko
I know exactly how that feels like I'm
just quarter movies yeah and so along
with that envelope he also gave them
instructions for a drop-off point like
where they can he can get the money
yeah well initially the cops they were
investigating the prostitute mmm this
girl is so popular it turns out like she
was cleared and then they finally traced
from the drop-off point and they saw the
police officer there and they also
traced the fact that like he he was able
to obtain that information by looking
into the database of the police station
so that's how he
he's using like state property yeah to
blackmail someone mm-hmm little [ __ ]
and then he's crying because it got
caught yeah he's crowd way it were where
does he police have to be that's like
that cop that raped those chicks
remember that one yeah oh yeah that's
the bad kind of black man in court he's
like effective it's Airy
you're a [ __ ] man do you remember use
use making girls like suck his dick and
stuff and all that yeah see that's the
kind of blackmail that's wrong this is
just business if it's UK cops I I kind
of sympathize cuz after we're funny
outfits you know not really tall a hat
that the other bobbies and no one takes
them serious I don't even have guns you
know that [ __ ] miniature baseball bat
they're supposed to be people with it
because they're so anti really big shoes
no no they have they're so anti-gun over
there that the cops don't even have guns
so they just have little miniature
baseball bat you're supposed to hit
people what happens when a crook points
a gun at a cop they have to run or
something well they have a very fast
like Swadesh yeah so the other four they
got a call into people the real cop with
real guns yeah it's kind of sucks damn
that's a totally different world yeah
he's he the blackmailer he looks like a
DJ Jared yeah DJ Garrett could spot him
in Vegas you know he chose the wrong
career he should have been a DJ
colleagues were saying he was such a
good police officer like he was a good
egg and it's oh here I'll show you guys
though they thought what a great eggs
benedict team just like his head he was
a great egg head so here's a clip of
when they arrested him he looks like an
egg with a beard I love this grown man
crying
[Music]
so I'm here to tell you Mary Poppins is
not coming back and they went on and
handcuffed him in the front and then
they put like a jacket over his
handcuffs so she wouldn't be dignity
damn that was classless
is he like a hacker policeman like one
of those computer cops like yeah I was
wondering to check out the headset he's
like yeah like I'm in the van yeah he's
not like a real cop like he's like those
nerd was like just me in the van and I'm
a six was creature I know you guys are
all hot up there
so yeah so he was from the organized
crime unit seems pretty specialized oh
you see we like to say you see in the
gang unit organized crime is a game
you'd yeah probably I don't know how I
feel about this I think bribes are okay
sometimes well we didn't say anything
about bribes we talked about blackmail I
guess it's kind of blackmail II and
Bribie you know but how would you like
to know that that your police force is
doing this now we all know that the
police force does do this on some just
like some bad eggs right I'd be sad
right you don't want that you got to
come down on guys but if I was the guy
that the cop came up to these I hate men
so you were going out with that hooker
and I was like all really but did you
see it now here's $100 there you go and
then he's like Sorry mate
and then like $200 that's right hey do
you take a card hold on because
extortion and bright is the same thing
is just who's asking first if the cop is
asking you hey I can make this go away
if you give me money right that's
extortion that's blackmail but if the if
the client is doing it that John is
saying it then that's a bribe but
they're both at all they're all wrong
though yeah I'm not saying that's right
I'm just saying if it was right you said
it was okay said it was great you said
it was better on what country okay if we
were in Mexico and I got pulled over and
I didn't do anything wrong I'll be like
yo you're just jacking me dude but if I
accidentally ran somebody over and I
don't want to deal with the court stuff
and then I give a money I think that's
different right that's okay oh I see
were saying yeah you're like already in
a scared position like because you got
in trouble you're not a police officer
yeah that's like why you hate like the
idea of getting arrested in Mexico is
like oh [ __ ]
like I'm have to go to ATM and give them
all my money oh yeah yeah oh that makes
sense
oh god oh I don't want to get robbed
that's true I just wanted no directions
I don't want them to take my money right
yeah if it's two civilians and they want
to bribe each other or whatever pay each
other off I think it's different but
when you have a cop involved they're
supposed to uphold the law
then that's when it's different that's
true out on like corruption I take it
back and then imagine uh getting
arrested by your own colleagues -
because he had that the man that was
talking to him he had just gone to a
conference two days prior to that so
they were like in the same sort of he
was like yeah I recognize you yeah now
you need to arrest me that's like
getting spanked by your own brother
it is embarrassing it's so very shared a
bagel next to the water cooler during
the conference yeah so he got jailed for
18 months but the Chief Constable felt
that that was not long enough and so
he's appealing for that to be increased
damn fools again they're doing it the
right way in the UK you know there's no
like blue veil over there just oh no
he's a piece of [ __ ] boom smash
something even harder I love it and then
should they should tree should do that
here yeah they should treat the cops
that [ __ ] up with like a crazier
sentence here they just go he got paid
leave might do that to our military you
got to pay leave in that military gets
in trouble and they go to jail like way
longer than a civilian was they have no
rights yeah cuz they waive the right
yeah that's true
they don't do it oh yeah those guys get
put away do whatever they want here yep
and they're still getting paid yeah paid
leave yeah so Gareth sentence was
doubled to three years and no turn
tables for three months poor guy
why wait why no I'm not sure I mean I
don't know when I see a man cry like
immediately when he's caught I'm like I
kind of feel bad for him you love your
father I kind of feel bad for love your
dad you guys have a great month is that
why you don't feel bad for me because I
don't cry yeah
crime or do I gotta cry at the tear
sticks but emotion is worth more than
robot yeah
there you go that's good it's working
look look she can't take her it's
working everybody oh she's not as fun as
I thought she was she's really fun she
was fun before no it's goodbye no he's
gonna keep pushing down and around and
under
[Applause]
that's I think its breath stinks what
about the other side gotcha
I use [ __ ] what is that witch hazel
thank you very much my dick is very
minty talk about your butthole all over
I have menthol and witch hazel which
thing it works really good on them hmm
remember the [ __ ] boat right yeah
yeah that's true he's sailing out
sometimes you know people are like yo
that joke was genius and I'm like whoa
okay they're laughing they said then you
watch it 16 times you're like war was a
joke
you'll say he's like sometimes you guys
laugh at stuff I say he's like I don't
even know why cause a lot it's because
it's gonna be an incomplete sentence and
that and then I'm always like okay what
I'm like waiting on my own where's the
rest of it and then he's like yeah oh
okay
so but he completes his thoughts with
yeah I noticed that during the writers
retreat cuz he would say something and
then here you go yeah look after he
finished saying it like oh so that's
your closed thought like that's that's
his peers your talent I'm done yeah yeah
I get you now I have to explain
everything to you guys I thought you
would already know we are living
you know that time that there was like
music playing and you're like I'm gonna
hurt you guys on here that's literally
your thoughts - we don't hear those and
I get in trouble constantly cuz I can't
hear his thoughts I get why I can't when
he gets mad at you though yeah yeah you
should know his but we all feel bad for
you don't worth context right everyone
doesn't feel bad for you everyone there
is no context yeah I could understand
all of you how come you can't understand
me cuz we're normal no you're not normal
and we finish our thoughts we do we
don't go yeah tired I just would like
how do I explain us these imbeciles okay
I'm done I can't explain any word you
say about Einstein being able to
communicate clearly knows the other top
oh I'm tired
[Music]